[Music]
hola amigos
what is up fix what's happening man it
is monday morning
it is around 9 00 a.m in beautiful los
angeles california
your boys back
i was on uh three-day
hiatus
three-day hiatus i missed one fighter
and the kid but chappelle and brian
cowan held it down
the
cheerleader and the kid held it down
your boy was in mexico with the fam just
for three days quick little trip to
mexico
um i suck at taking vacations man i'm
really bad at it my girl literally has
to drag me by the ears
to leave work
but uh i'm glad she did because i come
back refreshed a little tanner and just
so happy to be back at work man so i had
heads down for me man heads down nose to
the grindstone and just i go go go go
and then sometimes when i got out there
i was like oh i did need to take a break
i'm really bad at that one of the worst
traits about me is i just work non-stop
if you ask the fam um
yeah so mexico your boy had anxiety like
crazy out there i think just because i'm
getting older i don't know what's going
on i get anxiety these days
i had really bad anxiety i guess a bit
of it is from um
you know the news uh
partel stuff yeah like the news kind of
prides itself on click bay and you know
scaring
uh the population and so you know if
here in america we get a ton of stuff
about cartel this and they're beheading
people and putting people in vats of
acid and it's chaos and it's not safe
for americans
um but where we went in cabo
it's literally the safest place in
mexico
and uh
even then even then i still had just cr
i got no sleep out there
um
you know the the the
the fear-mongering worked on your boy
here i just got no sleep i was
always kind of stressed out had anxiety
about it
but then and we get this all the time we
get emails to find the kid or uh thick
boy all the time you know i talk about
mexico and how dangerous it is
you are more likely to get shot in la or
chicago than you are in mexico
so i i do and trust me i hear you man
and stats are there for a reason
but i guess the fear came from it's like
i know where to move in la where i'm not
going to get hurt i know the areas i can
go to there is i can't chicago same
thing detroit same thing whatever city i
go into when i'm on tour i know the i
know america man i know the areas to
stay out of and where you can get in
trouble stuff like that and mexico it's
kind of a free-for-all little bit
um you know really
cabba's the safest and the guy broke it
down to us so what happens you know my
girl is born and raised in uh mexico
so what she'll do is
if we have a driver we you know we're an
attack something like that chassis
speech speaks the native tongue and so
she just starts conversation with him
blah blah blah and then i'll tell him i
can't ask about cartel like sneak the
cartel stuff in there because if a white
boy asked this she might oh all safe and
then just drive you to your destination
but she'll get friendly with them and
then they'll become you know a friend
when you're out there for a few days
and then finally she was like hey as far
as the cartel and the way he broke it
down to her in spanish i had no idea
what the hell they were talking about
but she said because the it's on the
like the baja like peninsula and with
the navy
because it's it's touristy but the the
mexican navy made it so tough for the
cartel to
do their drug business there there's
like that's not big enough anyways [ __ ]
and then went to other places so cancun
is really the one you got to worry about
cancun right now i think five americans
have died in like the past two weeks
because what happened to cancun even and
in tulum a journalist died in a innocent
uh bystander died what's happening in
cancun
is there's a turf war because there's so
much tourist um
travel in and out of there
tourists ask for drugs they always want
drugs so
the three kind of cartels they are
fighting to take ownership of that area
and because a lot of those resorts are
so nice some of the cartel members will
hang out there in the bar so they're not
going after innocent americans or you
know killing them but you get kind of
the crossfire because they want to hang
out the nice places make sense they're
people you know they're just
you know bad people but they're people
that want nice food and drinks and to
chill like everybody else so they're
hanging out with the tourists and the
nice ears of cancun the other gangs see
that they start firing you're in the
crosshairs it's a
disaster but yeah your boy just had
crazy anxiety crazy anxiety out there
did not sleep well and then uh i pride
myself since i was a kid i don't uh i
don't drink a ton of water if i do it's
tap water that i grew up on as a child
so i don't drink a ton of water people
give me [ __ ] about all the time i don't
drink a ton of water and i don't use
sunscreen i just
refuse to use sunscreen since i was a
kid i've always looked like a native
american and i get really tan i never
burn
where we're at is like this little
private area where people really
you don't have to worry about anybody
it's just me and my family and i forgot
my swim trunks so i literally just wore
i wear whitey tighties i'm old school i
don't wear boxer briefs i don't wear
boxers that's that's stuff's for kids i
don't wear any of that trash i wear old
school boxer briefs so i mean not boxer
briefs but just straight up on these
like canes undies dude like my dad used
to wear he still does he wears the white
ones which i don't recommend for
multiple reasons but uh i wear colored
dark colored or light gray gray's the
lightest i'll go you know because you
wanna you don't camouflage would be
preferred if i'm being honest for a few
reasons you got the peepee standing in
the front the streaks out the back if
they're camel and nobody can tell
anything
cheat code for me undies but um
so i always go dark colored underoos and
i forgot my swim trunks because we were
rushing around the house i always wait
the last second to pack so i uh didn't
bring my swim trunks so i just wore my
undies as swim trunks my girl's like you
need sunscreen i said you've known me
for how long nine years have you ever
seen me put sunscreen on she's like no i
haven't got
anti-sunscreen baby i'm like you know
show them her face i'm like you're
mexican and you know i'm white and you
gotta worry about something cause she's
just lathering her and the kids up
whatever i'm making fun of them so your
boy didn't wear it
here's the thing though my upper body
and like below the knee gets all the sun
because i'm always riding my bike and my
face gets sun in my neck
but the the upper thighs and like in the
inside my thighs don't they don't get a
lot of rays
well because i was in the sun for three
days your boy
got third degree burns from that mexican
sun dude i can barely sit down right now
she was not lying i really should have
listened and put sunscreen on it really
[ __ ] my world up it is no joke make
sure you sunscreen kids it is no joke at
all
but uh i'm glad to be back man it's
gorgeous out there and uh kids had a
blast i didn't realize how much i needed
a break because your boy hits the ground
running man we hit the frickin
ground running because um
you know the you just got a busy week
man the special drops uh this month so
the whole team here i know mike's been
working his ass off the edits the
the sizzles the promos lining up all the
marketing the the podcast pr tour and
the cover of it and shooting and all
that it's been a long time coming man so
that drops april 28th on thick boy
and uh i think we'll give the first
sizzle or trail you'll see the first
commercial uh during the fight campaign
this saturday at 7 00 pm
uh on thick boy we for the fight
campaign for ufc where we 273 yep you
have uh main event volkanovsky and the
korean zombie uh for that fight can pay
at 7 pm live we have brian callan matt
matrione josh thompson and myself you
got the boys coming out it's been a
grand old time
watch the fights with us or watch it on
sunday or monday if you want to you know
tune in to the actual professionals call
the fight but if you want to be uh
you know if you want to get dumber and
listen to us uh talk about who knows
what uh probably my tan for about three
hours tune in to us that's the calabasas
fight campaign this saturday at 7 p.m
with matriarch josh thompson brian
callum and myself
so yeah man glad to be back but god dang
do we hit the ground running this april
man
your boy gots billboards and it's all
self-funded
that's the cool thing about this
is um
i made a decision a few weeks ago
um
just everything i'm doing you know i've
obviously stepped away from
showtime that's why you're watching this
on thick boy i just decided to take
control of my own business and do it all
by myself you know obviously have a team
to have a staff but i just wanted to do
it the way exactly how i want to do it
and obviously takes time takes time to
grow and stuff like that which i'm never
afraid of
and then with the special
i shot it with my team in in dallas that
that's an improv you won't even be able
to tell that's an improv because we
completely redesigned the uh the
background and the stage and stuff like
that shout out to brian johnson and we
made it kind of the dallas skyline with
some stars in the back it's pretty dope
you'll see it soon
and so uh yeah i brought my whole team
out there we shot it on these fancy
cameras where they read sony camera or
some [ __ ] mike
my boy peter and dallas helped out as
well um
[Music]
so yeah just my whole team shot this
thing we shot it edit it and then uh we
shopped it around and we had several
offers from uh
from companies and businesses you guys
would all know where every other comic
is at and uh we're my team as far as tm
team i mean manager and agents were you
know they're in hollywood so like oh
let's go here with it or let's go here
with it or you should take this and this
and i was gonna do it man i was waiting
for the one i wanted most to land and it
landed
and i thought that's what i wanted
and then uh about like i said they said
all right well we'll just
we're waiting for the contract soon we
get you sign it and that's how much
they're gonna pay you and blah blah blah
so okay that's cool and then uh i fell
asleep that night woke up at three in
the morning like dude
you're doing all this [ __ ] on your own
everything man the fight companion the
food trucks the flashback fight nights
firing the kid king the sting
the shop show that you have your own
studio the whiskey
the thick boy merch i'm just doing all
this on my own
and then
i'm i'm not anti-hollywood i'm far from
that i respect what they do but i'm
definitely not hollywood i don't
consider myself a celebrity any facet
and then here i am waiting for the
approval on you know these major
companies which we got which i'll be
honest feels good especially
where i'm at in the game as far as stand
up i always look for that validation
because you know i feel like i'm the
punter on the football team when it
comes to stand-up comedy you know like
yeah you're you're on the team but
you know you gotta prove yourself which
you know i don't think i'll ever get
over that but that's my own doing
so we got the approvals and then you
know the moon tower comedy festival
comes along these other festivals come
along which is all fine and dandy
and um
it just something didn't feel right it
just it didn't feel
um like it was the right choice to make
for me as an individual
and i know uh the agents and managers
worked hard on selling this thing and
we've shopped around i met with all
these people and
you know when when you go okay what can
you guys do and they tell you what they
can do every single man went ah man i
bet i could figure that out i bet i
could do that myself man you have you
know
monetarily the money you would get from
it's cool but i feel like
all the stuff that they offer and all
these comics are waiting for these
approvals and they think you know
getting a billboard or this commercial
or this or that is a big deal and it is
but you don't need them to do it you
really don't and um
so i woke up that next morning and i
think two i'm a little salty at
mainstream in hollywood too the way
they've treated
a number of my friends particularly joe
rogan
and i just thought man you've talked all
this [ __ ] and you've supported these
guys and then you're waiting for
validation from these hollywood
executives which
you got because they gave you several
offers on your special
but it just doesn't seem like uh
the right fit for me
so i woke up the next morning and i
called the team my agents and managers
and said
hey i'm gonna put on thick boy i'm gonna
i'm gonna bet on myself i'm gonna put on
thick boy
it just seems like the right thing to do
obviously they argued that they're not
huge fans of it because i'll see and
it's
their job this is what they do they go
well this is the reason you should go
with this this platform and this and
obviously they get 10 of whatever they
give but if it's on fake boy nobody gets
anything me and the team
and the way this business is structured
what i get the team gets as well so
everybody's compensated
so um i just told them that that was the
move i'm releasing myself and i want to
prove to uh
other comics out there you know i i know
how
nerve-wracking is getting validation
from these big companies and
entertainment businesses and get on
their platforms but
you don't need it you don't need it you
really don't you can do it yourself and
uh
if any comic out there actually wants me
to break it down financially you know
from shooting to the billboards to the
commercials to the sizzles
the marketing the photography
everything i would gladly sit down with
you and break it all down for me and i
think
once you have a clear idea on what
exactly goes into tunic special the
cameraman
the editing the
the coloring the sound quality
um the billboards the sizzles the
commercials the photo shoots all that
stuff and then the pr tour you look at
that and go i got a man yeah and i can
control everything i can put as many
clips as i want i can edit this i can
say this i don't have to worry about you
know i had some new some jokes in there
and a certain corporation like that well
who gives a [ __ ] man you can do it
yourself so
that's what i'm doing man that's what
i'm doing and uh i know it's the right
choice
i know you guys are gonna rally behind
it and prove me right
i know it and i can't wait for it april
28th and uh you see the first uh
commercial fort uh during the fight
companion saturday at 7 p.m it's on
thick boy youtube so that's it man but
others other than that
business as usual man business as usual
you just got a little more uh
forks in the fire when you're doing
stuff like this so i'm i'm super excited
man i've worked hard on this i've worked
really hard on this so i'm really
excited but i'm even more excited for
uh the
the big pay-per-view this saturday the
ufc has taken you know some some weeks
off which is fine everybody needs a
vacation which i understand i took a
vacation myself
and they come back with a uh a hell of a
fight card for you i listen
great fight card i still i i know
i'm riding uh london's nuts i still
don't think it's better from top to
bottom than the ufc fight night in
london that was free that would
definitely complain for i really don't
that was my favorite card this year the
performances lived up to it it's gonna
be tough to beat that
but this card from top to bottom pretty
god damn good man pretty pretty freaking
good
the main card uh on the pay-per-view is
stacked you know you had a kelvin gassum
fall out um but you know it's not the
end of the world as much as i love
kelvin you know they they filled it you
know you have five solid fights that i
think people are gonna pay for the
prelims solid uh ian gary's a monster at
welterweight they're giving him kind of
the attention that he needs
uh anthony hernandez is a fun one
rosenstru kicks it off with uh tibera
shoot a bit of a crossroads for him
right following some hard times our boy
mickey galls uh the main event on the
prelims um
you know but it's let's stick the main
card as far as the main card go
you know it took a little bit of a hit
with volkanovsky alexander the great
was supposed to fight max holloway which
is a fight i'm dying to see again i'd
watch that every saturday take my
freaking money dana white but uh he got
injured so he pulled out and
then you know who knows how bad the
injury is but it's also
you know if you're a max hallway fanboy
which i am i love max he's been on food
truck getting him back out here soon
which we should hit him up but i
absolutely love max but
if you are fanboy max you know for him
to pull out of a fight it had to be
pretty serious and then when he pulls
out and then goes you know what i'm
actually better maybe the injury wasn't
as bad as he thought and you know
he came back and i assume he's the
the kind of
waiting in the wings here i'm sure he's
going to be at the fight in case zombie
or volkanovsky doesn't make weight or
somebody gets injured he'll be there but
that was the fight we all wanted
but i'm not mad at a korean zombie you
know to to get a shot at the title
obviously he's at the tail end of his
career and he's been a fan favorite for
a while and i'll tell you something
about korean zombies never boring is
never involved in a boring fight just
not in his dna
and he also has the potential to be the
first and i think you'll know this jen
if he wins he'll be the first korean
yeah champion can't wait for him ufc you
think it's gonna happen i don't know man
but i'm always taking greens on before
you have to yeah you absolutely have to
yeah you have to it's uh a tough task
very tough very tough to ask but um
that being said you know
there's certain guys when they get the
the call up you know whether it's title
shot or last second replacement the
certain guys were like this is this
isn't the easiest fight in the world
because we know korean zombie comes out
like a god damn korean banshee hits like
a mack truck
pretty damn good at grappling which i
think is his best chance to uh finish
volkanovsky is if volkanovsky were to
get him down or you know he was able to
get his back or something like that
that's what you got to hope for um but
korean zombie also has a ton of
experience too so the moment's not too
big for him he's been in a title fight
before you know against uh jose aldo so
he's been there before so he has a lot
of things going for him
it's just we don't give alexander the
great volkanovsky and his nickname is
the great for a reason enough credit for
how goddamn good he is man you know he
uh was he won 11 in a row or some [ __ ]
like that
look at that man he hasn't lost in a hot
second and he's beat the who's who
who's the guy who beat him go down
he lost in 2013
in melbourne australia to corey nelson
shout out to cory nelson not sure what
he's doing these days
but either way hats off to you my man
since then though and [ __ ] happens in
mma that was his fourth professional
fight uh that was the afc welterweight
tournament quarterfinal that he lost
well he bounced back from that has won
every single fight
every single fight and he's beat the
who's who man oh my god darren elkins
chad mendez jose aldo max holloway twice
and then brian ortega the brian ortega
is one of the greatest freaking fights
at featherweight of all time i think we
all gain more respect for brian ortega
after that also
you gain more respect for volkanovsky
the great because he was in some serious
trouble he was about to go out and trust
me man when brian ortega gets your neck
and i've been there he stroked me out
many of times when he gets your neck
there's not much you can do there's
nobody in the featherweight division
with better jiu jitsu especially as far
as go as far as he goes is finishing
once he gets a hold of your neck you
give him a god damn inch he takes a mile
and he's going to finish you and
volkanovsky was in some serious trouble
and to me
you know i know the fans and the hype
comes from guys finishing guys but to me
you can invest in a volkanovsky the
great because you know when the going
gets rough he's gonna answer the
freaking bell dude and he's a true and
true
world champion the best featherweight we
have to offer his only
kind of black eye and this is weird to
say no pun intended the only black guy
in his resume is the max holloway fights
and i would caveat that with the reason
why it's a black guy is because max
holloway is so beloved he's such a fan
favorite he's such a good person he's
been around for so long everyone
absolutely i don't know anybody who
doesn't like max holloway i don't know
what social media is or if he has haters
i'm sure everybody has haters but it's
tough to hate on max holloway and
because he's so beloved and so
so
just the nicest guy in the world
people they want him to win and so when
those are close fights and there's a
split decision
somebody thought max won this one some
some people thought volkonovsky won this
one what i think happens there
is you know it's just unfinished
business and the ufc was going to give
us that finished business
but holly got hurt
so
if you're
volkanovsky there's nothing you can do
man you go out there you fight max
always as tough as they come it was a
split decision but you got the nod move
on what can you do and if i'm
volkanovsky just for my legacy i want
that third trilogy rubber match with max
hallway and you want to put them away
decisively so you shut up everybody yeah
that's the only way to get it done you
got to beat him convincedly can't do
another split decision because then we
need a fourth but if you put him away
you did it you did it everybody shuts
the hell up but if you lose then you
have a fourth fight which again take my
money so for alexander volkanovsky it's
a bit of uh
you know he's a pros pro so he knows
that korean zombie chan seung jung
is definitely a formal opponent and
poses a lot of
um risk inside that octagon he's a
veteran hits like a mack truck as a
granite chin that's where the name
korean zombie came from he's very
dangerous on the ground
so i'm intrigued by this fight i'm
intrigued because
i think korean zombie going into it has
nothing to lose and that is a dangerous
korean zombie do i think he's going to
win absolutely nothing
i definitely absolutely not absolutely
not oh my god we got to bed again we can
not 500 bucks no yeah let's just bet a
bottle of whiskey all right that's cool
all right all right my you
let's do this um
if
chan seung jung wins if korean zombie
wins you can pick any bot you could even
pick pappy's you can pick anybody you
want up to three thousand dollars
if alexander volkanovsky wins just get
me a bottle of buffalo tracy all right i
think it's 40 bucks a deal that's it i
mean he's also a minus 600.
it's not like you're doing me a solid
here right you know it's not like you
know so you can have a papi van vincus
and i'll have a buffalo trade all right
deal yeah because the chance and wins
not good but still a fun bet
dude first korean champion ever
um that'd be sick it's not happening but
that would be so amazing yeah i'd be
sick you never know you never know and
listen we love korean zombies we rock
his gears team sends us gear we love
green zombie dude
dude where the [ __ ] is our shoe i was
just talking to mike about this i'm like
i gotta text them or email them tai two
of us a dude i love you dude trying to
show support i'm gonna take down my most
exclusive shoe i've ever received the
kanye nike
kick my most expensive shoe that i own
is that kick some of the shoe surgeon
kicks they sent me are like one of ones
those might be up there
but as far as like straight sneakers
that's it papa that and i have a few
off-whites that are getting up there
especially since virgil passed away rest
in peace but that's it dude that's my
most prized possession of a kick i'm
willing to take that down and put in
your shoei if it arrives dude we got to
get better at shipping and handling
where's the customer service dog what's
up baby they texted me on march 12th on
saturday and what'd they say
your order from iwasa has been shipped
because come from australia it's a bit
of a it's coming here yeah straight to
the studio
i'm just messaging back right now so
yeah hopefully oh you can text with them
that's cool
um yeah i'm excited for uh alexander the
great just uh
you know but again he gets everyone
expects him to get by this in flying
colors i don't think it's gonna be that
easy for him i do think he's gonna
struggle a little early on
because green zombies such a korean
banshee he's going to come out and give
people a little bit of hope and then
volcano season and take over he's going
to destroy him in the stand up the leg
kicks the hands he's going to take he's
going to break him down that's how this
is going to go down does he get a finish
tough to say tough to say but definitely
could i it's a tough tough fight for
korean zombie but that first second
round's gonna be lit as [ __ ]
um the co-main event you had al jermaine
sterling the bantamweight champion with
an asterisk right and you got peter yan
uh the interim champ
um this fight listen these these first
three ones are all intriguing because
you can paint a story for any of them
but with al jermain sterling peter yan
there's actual bad blood they do not
like each other al jamaine sterling got
the championship belt uh he was getting
absolutely annihilated by peter yan
and then uh peter yan threw an illegal
knee
which i thought was definitely illegal
was al james sterling hurt that bad i
don't know chin has skeptical hippo eyes
either way he became world champion from
it
and uh
he was really humble inside the octagon
and then somebody got his ear and said
dude you're the champ act like it run
with this and he's ran with it
you know it's become a little bit uh
to quote triple c's fan base a little
bit cringe-worthy but i also get it like
your champ that is what it is man
uh relish in it and but also
i don't know how long he's going to keep
it because as soon as p john's ready to
go
we saw how that kind of the the early
onset
of the fight between them was not
great for al jermain and i had al
jermaine go into that fight i had him
kind of beat him peter young and i i
apologize pedian his fan base
um i never was on the pedian train until
that fight and then i was like holy [ __ ]
and then you see him against corey
sandhya you're like holy [ __ ] this boy
is the real deal
so
both in the main event co-main event i
owe both guys an apology because
you know with alexander volkonovsky and
peter young i've never been like on
their hype train you know i've always
respected them and i love watching them
fight but i've never been like on their
nuts you know
um but now with uh vulkanovsky i hang on
his nuts like a koala bear peter yan
he's just uh this [ __ ] killer who's
good at everything i thought al jermain
sterling's athleticism
his kind of unorthodox jiu jitsu and
wrestling might you give peter yan some
trouble
that was not the case periodon was toss
them all all around that goddamn octagon
um he's just a better fighter than al
james sterling so for al jermaine
who hasn't been active since he won the
belt he had surgery on his neck he's
been inactive peter yon's been active
he's been training he's been healthy and
he has this built up aggression towards
al-jamin sterling
um you know alger maine's been chilling
resting probably hasn't been able to do
too much training before he got in this
camp because of the neck issues period
beat a guy named corey sanderhagen who's
no [ __ ] joke at bantamweight
so you know this is another one where
it's a bit of a land slide for peter yan
i think
similar to the main event i think that
the first round al jamaine is going to
come out and and do his thing and try to
learn from that first match up but at
the end of the day i just think peter
young's too good
so the early rounds for al jamaine and
korean zombie are gonna be fun they're
gonna be fun and unless they get a
finish in the first or early
minutes of the second round these things
can get nasty and i really think
the difference between volkanovsky and
korean zombie and al jamaine and peter
young matchups is it volkanovsky and
korean zombie volkanovsky just has all
the respect in the world two nice guys
all good in the co-main event with alger
mainstream period they freaking hate
each other dude they there's bad blood
there peter young does not respect him
period knows he's the real champion so i
think peter younes can go out there make
a statement man and i don't think they
they you know they like hug and you know
are best friends after this fight either
i think peter yohn's gonna make a
statement and make it pretty brutal now
jermaine that needs to be a real [ __ ]
beat down man i gotta be honest and
that's no shade on al jermain i just
don't like his the matchup i don't going
into the first match i had sterling
winning i thought stylistically he was a
bit of a nightmare for peter yan i
overlooked pedryanna and realize how
freaking unstoppable how good he is and
just that world championship
tenacity and aggression that he has and
jesus christ is that boy good
but the co-main event and main event are
fantastic but let's be honest let's be
honest let's be honest oh yeah if i'm
the ufc
and this is no shade at those four
gentlemen fighting in the main event
co-main event i would just make a poster
with homs on it it would just say hamzat
usd 273
the hype is real as real as it gets
hamza
shamayov is an absolute [ __ ] monster
he's ranked number 11 he's fighting the
number two guy in the world for a reason
he's jumping the q because he's that
goddamn good
and uh again this is no shade on gilbert
burns he's an amazing fighter he's
number two at welterweight for a reason
he had the the world champion the
pound-for-pound goat uh camaro who's
been rocked in a bit of trouble and
obviously he gives them all he can
handle and practice that's what everyone
kept telling me practice practice
practice i told you practice doesn't
mean [ __ ] and we learned that in that
fight
so gilbert burns is one of the best
welterweights we have to offer
phenomenal jiu jitsu
world champion the gui multiple times
and you know he's beat some guys and
i think if you're a hamzat hater again i
don't know if hamzad has haters i
i don't know what you'd hate on
but if you look at
uh if you are a gilbert guy and you're
like man gilbert can give this get this
done
look what he did against one boy
thompson right he he took him down and
held him and you know did his thing
controlled the fight and was never
really in trouble with wonder boy and he
took him down he only has four losses
sure sure i get all that
but then i want you to step back and
think about this he had wonder boy
for 15 minutes completely controlled him
on the ground couldn't submit wonder boy
who's maybe a purple belt
you think he's going to take
hamza shimaya down and control him and
submit hanzo
a bigger better grappler not a chance
not a chance i ju and this is no shade
on gilroy i know it sounds like i'm
throwing shayla and get her i'm not
hanzai i'm telling you man i'm so high
on homs at
nothing is better to me in this [ __ ]
world in any sport
than when a prospect is coming up
through the ranks and there's these
urban legends about his training camp
and what he does to gus finn and latifi
and his coaches tell me you haven't seen
[ __ ] and then you know he beats the
brakes off your boy jinglang beats the
[ __ ] out of him
and goes from there and goes to a
grappling match against a middleweight
and molly wops him
the amount of hype and mythical stories
that we've heard about hamzat and just
the come up and there's no reason we
shouldn't believe it because every time
he's performed he's validated this
insane hype train and i am all for it i
am hanging off is dagger standing nuts
harder than anybody you're gonna listen
to i think he is the most talented
fighter we've seen in [ __ ] years
he is a conor mcgregor
dagestanian but bigger
more skilled
overall
and more tenacity he's a mean
[ __ ] dude he's just this badass
he's this mythical
logical creature he's the [ __ ]
he's that bigfoot in dak standing he's
the bigfoot in sweden that we never get
to see finally we get to see him we get
to see him against the number two
[ __ ] welterweight in the world and
what's insane to me is saying this i
think he mops the floor with gilbert
burns i think he absolutely annihilates
him and what's even crazier is i don't
see anybody on the ufc roster giving him
any sorts of [ __ ] issues that's
what's crazy to me and that's what i
love i know it's romantic i'm a romantic
i love the story i love the narrative of
this dagger standing [ __ ] monster
doing this thing
i love all of it and i'm all here for it
take my [ __ ] money if the ufc said
hey it's a hundred dollars and you can
only watch harms that fight i would
[ __ ] pay it in a heartbeat any time
he fights i'm on the god damn hamza
train know if he has merch let me know
chin i'm [ __ ] buying it hopefully he
has his own merch and i know him and
darren till are [ __ ] besties now and
hopefully darren till's taking a thing
or two from him and he's gonna parlay
and something else i know how's that
launch his own youtube channel which is
[ __ ] blowing up as well the guy's
just crushing it dude he's crushing it
this is ufc store and merch hopefully he
has his own merch
i wonder if he has his own welcome out
by
have you ever seen anybody rocking the
[ __ ] uh
i guess reeboks out they don't even they
still do fight kick
kids though don't they what
venom the venom does the fight kits now
is it
also his he has a website but it's not
it says coming soon so he'll probably
have merch after oh my god that guy
would make a fortune off merch yeah
the cool merch you could do with that
dude
let's look at the fight kits here
mike's just hoping he wins because mike
has a hamza rookie card worth how much
mike
three or four grand right now becomes
champ that goes up to what
you're going to sell it
if he gets attending usl yeah i mean
it's fight game how long can you know i
don't know
so you got the authentic one ah
actually it has the big crypto thing so
but this is harms i care this is just
there you go shirt
hoodie shirt
that looks pretty cool
you're not digging it
i mean it does look cool it looks very
it's very under armour-ish right like
you're gonna
i would use this first thing something a
little more hanzo was looks so much
cooler i think than shimada
i mean there's nothing that just blows
me eye on that it's just so basic how do
they not focus on
hamza what's the back say
i am your king
i mean they're cool merc the boogeyman
merch i am your king
not met that shirt
i don't wear a ton of blue but
it looks like a cool baseball type shirt
uh this product ships from a third party
product could take initial 7 10 business
days of ship from the vendor product
time will be 7 10 business days
regardless of shipping option chooses oh
well that's not ideal
i'm all here for it though and also at
you know he
when he fought jinglang he uh
his camp was worried about him getting
to welterweight right and because he's
such a big welterweight and it's his
advantage in in so many aspects from the
grappling to the power everything he's a
bigger welterweight he's going to be
massive massive
as far as physically over gilbert burns
gilbert burns is a smaller welterweight
so he's a big
favorite for a reason the first three
five i'm sorry the last three fights on
the main card are all
complete mismatches as far as vegas odds
go now does that mean they're gonna be
landslides nope oh check me out does
that mean this can be landslide you know
minute finishes no i don't think that um
oh that's your card mike's card
[Music]
sealed the sealed
mike's stoked mike collects cards he
does mike nothing wrong with that man no
man i'm all about it
um
so you know hamza i i will say this for
a hamzat fan
i think he has
i'll be kind of
conservative on this i think he's gonna
he has two more fights at welterweight
before he's sick of
being on a diet all the goddamn time
i know he was in shape for a fight two
months ago he was walking around at the
the weight to make welterweight at 170.
so he's a bigger guy so what i think
happens is uh hamza beats gilbert burns
if he goes in there absolutely starches
him like i'm talking a minute two
minutes just molly wops gilbert burns
he puts the ufc in quite the predicament
because
the ufc has promised leon edwards the
title shot
god has he earned it right we all want
leon edwards to get what he deserves
he's earned it but the ufc is giving
such a tough spot because
the demand for hamza to get a title shot
if he completely beats the [ __ ] out of
gilbert burns
is going to be so insane
and the ufc is about money they're about
money they're not about
doing the right thing all the time
but you know kamar husband is coming off
surgery there has been no official
announcement of him versus on edwards in
july or uh june or or august
so
with that not being confirmed unless
they confirm it this week the ufc is
being quite the predicament they really
are man
because if hamzap mops the floor with
gilbert burns number two guy in the
world
what do you do we know what's going to
get numbered
we know what's going to get numbers and
it's kamara versus hamza yeah and
hamzat's not going to be around what to
wait too long
um and also hamza again one of the
reasons i love him reminds me such of
connor when he's coming up he doesn't
want to just sit on the shelf he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about your title he's
already said if they give conor the
title shot it makes sense yeah dude he's
a huge star he's trying to make money
whatever they want to do
he doesn't care about that stuff he just
wants to compete at all costs
so
if the ufc does go all right the hanzo
we hear the demand from the fans you
beat the gilbert burns you deserve a
title shot we're going to give it to you
but it's probably not going to be till
december maybe early 2023 depending how
leona where leon edwards and newsman
does
which is another fight we can get into i
do think that's a tougher fight for
kamar usman um but lin you're telling me
leon edwards beat hamzat
tough fight
tough fight
so i i do think uh the ufc is gonna do
the right thing i'm just saying they're
going to be a bit of a pretty
predicament i do think they're in duly
under where it's uspin sometime mid late
summer
but hamzat if he gets past the way i
think he's going to get past gilbert
burns
he's not going to wait he wants to
compete and then you got a guy
who has a ton of press a ton of eyeballs
on him right now for i would say the
wrong reasons in colby covington against
you know his issues with mozville at the
steakhouse in miami where you're sucker
punched
but you do hamzad vs kobe covington
that's what you do
you gilbert he gilbert burns you pass
that test you give him the next guy in
line because he'll be ranked number two
so you give him kobe covington and then
he'll just wait for kumar usman and then
it's on to the middleweights
because he's naturally a middleweight
and you know they're they're they have
our guy [ __ ] uh he's even ranked the
yeah they have sean strickland number
four so then you have sean strickland
uh is facing the guy
who beat
um izzy in kickboxing knocked him out
him climbing through the rankings and i
do think uh strickland's underdog in
that fight which is surprising to me i
you know from what i've seen you know
the guy's a stud the guy is an absolute
stud
but um i i do think it's a big jump to
go to sean strickland from what he's
been competing at but if he were to beat
uh sean strickling
you know then then you have that fun
story of which i'm sorry of izzy um
first what's his name chin alex pahea
bahia
that makes sense but outside that the
middle weight division has nothing to
offer so homsey comes right in there you
have izzy hamzat dude so many awesome
matches
and then we're going scizzler because
also um with the strength and what he
does in training camp
you got light heavyweight too
who wants it daddy who wants it hamzat
has the potent this is what i absolutely
[ __ ] adore about the ufc and there's
nothing like it there's absolutely
nothing like it a little bit of a
patrick mahomes vibe i guess you know he
was picked late and then comes in and
you know they they have uh
chiefs have their starting quarterback
and alex smith and they take a chance
and this young rookie from texas tech
who
got to be honest
turned the ball over in college and
didn't blow your hair back but he's a
gunslinger comes in the nfl and he's the
best quarterback in the nfl now not
named aaron rodgers shout out to him
rogers but he's up there man he's
[ __ ] dangerous
his come up was cool
very cool took the nfl by storm
hamza similar to that man where he has
the potential to just take over the ufc
for the first time he's a smaller guy
he's not [ __ ] around 145 like connor
did and 55 then can you know really
shouldn't be fine at 70 but he can if
it's the right match up hamza guy at 170
is the best in the world at 185 we will
see against izzy i'm still obviously
super high and izzy and that light
heavyweight he can [ __ ] around and play
the game in all three of those divisions
it is fantastic
the world is your oyster my man the
world is your oyster
and it is so goddamn exciting now what's
gonna be hilarious
is if he gets absolutely starch on
saturday by gilbert burns and you guys
watch this and then i get all the smoke
from gilbert burn fans
which i encourage that it would be
hilarious and all this hype stops which
is also
awesome to see too it's hilarious
that's how hard that that's the fight
game man mike's just worried about his
card and making money but the fight game
will humble anybody but
i ju with homs i just don't see a hole
in his game yet i just don't
i just don't not yet i you know the the
only guy to give him issues that
middleweight would be izzy with his
the match-ups but
if he goes in there and does what we
think he's capable of doing against
gilbert burns it's gonna get so scary in
a great way and it's so romantic and
it's so hollywood it's a marvel movie
he's a [ __ ] he's the boogie man it's
so [ __ ] dope
and it's also terrifying too because as
much
i haven't been talking [ __ ] but as much
gas that i've given hamzat
the fight game is such a s
[ __ ] it's such a cold-hearted
[ __ ] all this could stop if he loses
gilbert burns on saturday that's why
this is fun the stakes are so high
and my god if there's a stock i'm
investing in homsat dude you guys
[ __ ] know this he's a [ __ ] problem
at welterweight at middleweight at light
heavyweight i would i would back him
against anybody in the world the only
fight i'm not crazy for him about is is
he because izzy's a bad [ __ ] i
still believe this if aliens came down
like
all right man we're going to blow up
this earth but we're going to keep the
ufc but we're only going to keep a few
fighters who should we watch i'd say
watch izzy right now i say watch izzy
now come saturday
come saturday
if hamza beats the [ __ ] out of gilbert
burns i'd say watch hamzat
he's a [ __ ] savage and that'd whisper
in the alien's air what he did what he
planned to do to conor mcgregor talk
[ __ ] about a guy he doesn't even know
because they're both dagestanian and
he's gonna fly the [ __ ] dublin beat
the [ __ ] out of him
i'd whisper that in the aliens there and
say for reals i'll say yeah doug that's
what you're dealing with
and nobody's been able to figure him out
take him
take him but also take me because i'm
the hype train
i'm his hype man i'm his flavor flav
that's what i am
the and if i'm the ufc dude the poster
is ju this is no shade on any of the
champions
the poster is just hamzat
and then everybody else small at the
bottom
that's what i do
that's what i'd be very black and white
with everybody i'd be very honest
we're all in on him man we're trying to
make him the biggest star in the world
you see his youtube numbers you see his
social media following
this guy has shown no
chinks in the armor
zero
giant hanzo everybody else small ufc 273
hamzat buy it
very black buy it
or else
be sick be amazing
don't do a dope poster like he's the
boogie man like he's underneath the
kid's bed
that'd be sick there's so much cool [ __ ]
he could do
i'd make videos of him like walking
through the forest like bigfoot but just
with hums that's like face and beard
there's so much cool [ __ ] you can do
let's take a little break from all the
fight shenanigans because a few
housekeeping notes keep the lights on
keep the boys employed because i gotta
pay people to run the show man there are
two titles up for grabs on this stack
ufc 273 fight card you can watch it with
your boys cal bass fight company 7pm
live on the think boy youtube but you're
gonna watch it you're gonna make some
bank because you're gonna join the
action with draftking sportsbook the
official sporting
sports
the official sports betting partner of
the ufc new customers can bet five
dollars on any fighter and get one
hundred dollars in free bets win or lose
guaranteed i would bet on your boy hamza
that's what i would do if sportsbook
isn't available in your state yet you
can still get in on the excitement
everyone can play for a share of
millions in prizes with draftkings daily
fantasy mma contest draft your lineup of
fighters while staying under the salary
cap and rack up points for strikes
takedowns and more draftkings is safe
secure reliable best of all you can
deposit withdraw your cash whenever you
want no issues download the draftking
sportsbook app right now use promo code
shobb sch aub throw down just five
dollars on ufc 273 and get one hundred
dollars in free bets no matter what
that's code chob this saturday after at
draftking sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the ufc must be 21 or
older restrictions apply see show notes
for details mackenzie dern
shout out to the mama there finest mama
in the ufc women's strawweight versus
tisha torres
teacher taurus has her hands full i
think mackenzie turns a slight favorite
off because of jitsu
my only worry and you guys know this
i've been on mckenzie during titties for
quite some time now um no pun intended
but the i've been on her tits for a
while now uh obviously a
strikingly beautiful woman but then also
her skills are undeniable
and because she's been at rooka
she's fallen in love with her striking
and i you know it it worries me a little
bit because you can't get away from what
got you to the dance if you've been
doing the cha-cha the entire time it's
getting this far and all of a sudden you
want to [ __ ] start doing the waltz
hey man let's get back to the cha-cha
switch against tisha torres who fans
herself a grappler and choke her out
mackenzie let's do that i want to see
that world-class jiu jitsu i know you're
papa
mega megaton wants to see it as well
let's get back to the old roots girl and
i think she will i think she gets a uh
rear naked joke in the second round
um yeah ola nick ben derrera
good card i'm excited for you and gary
who's an absolute [ __ ] monster trying
to build him like i said before
rosenstrok bit of a crossroads for him
and his career tiberius no punk
and we'll see what happens with
rosenstein but good card man
so hopefully i get you guys excited i'll
thank you side for ufc 273 this mother
trucking saturday your boy has a long
saturday because uh i signed up for
these things called tough mudder
and it's my third one this year
and last one i ran with
no hamstrings and it was a complete
nightmare but your boy got through it
because we had over 400 people sign up
so i had to show up
um but we have one this saturday uh
contractual i think after four years my
third ones have one more to go but this
time i have both hamstrings so it's
gonna be a grand old time i'm looking
forward to it it's in san bernardino
california
um
this obstacle course this terrain is
much more
it's more difficult because a lot of
it's so uphill it's a beast but it's
just a better
it's a better
experience than the one we did last time
which was out by lake elsinore which it
was all flat it was around the lake it
was too flat for me but they listened to
me because i was like where's the mud
they said you say mud and it was all the
mud in the world every [ __ ] obstacle
was mud but this one
um have to colorado once chin that's
fine uh but this one is in san
bernardino at the uh it's kind of a
racetrack out there but it is so much
fun man april 9th
it is april 9th and uh los angeles
they say los angeles they do that for
the other one it's at the
glen helen raceway oh i know that area
yeah it's so much fun you see that it's
like you're on the mountains and it's so
much fun dude if you're the the thick
mudder if you keep scrolling down you
see a thick mudder the thick mudder uh
we all start at 10 30 a.m is our uh
start time and we're offering a 15k and
a 5k
so you're probably looking at this and
you've seen the hype videos that we make
you're like i'm not in shape for that
i'm [ __ ] i'm telling you guys i'm
telling you it's about the experience we
help each other out
um i run with everybody and it's just
such a good freaking time man it's such
a good time friendship thick mudder wave
there it is
there it is
15k 5k if you use the promo code thick
boy save 10 off which you know is a good
amount of money to to get into this race
i think it's like 120 bucks to do it so
you save december money you know 10 off
um but we have 470 people signed up
already for this one which is nutsos
and then uh
we have the thick boy shirt that's
dropping as well that's at thickboy.com
i it's saturday so if you order it now
definitely not getting it in time but
that's okay we well enough people have
ordered
they still have it up or they take it
down looks like it's down go down scroll
down
oh they took it down yeah because you
wouldn't get in time because just for
that race but it's there man
it is there
so i can't wait for that man your boy
has both hand me so it's gonna be a
grand old time
we have some other merch we just dropped
on thickboy.com so get you some right
now
all right jim what do we got
all right
computer's a little slow today but so
this happened stefan bonner he's been
he's had a huge streak of bad luck as of
late
so apparently his house
got burned how pretty they don't know
exactly what happened yet dude
i'm trying to make this about myself
because it's all about stephen bonner
will get to and um he has a gofundme i'm
sure oh yeah we'll donate to right now
i'll donate two thousand dollars to that
but um
i well you know i'm on carnivore diet i
had three cheat meals in mexico felt
terrible that's one reason i couldn't
sleep i realized when i eat carbs for
dinner i don't i'll wake up at three in
the morning just be [ __ ] so i
carnivore for life here carnivore daddy
but um
i cook steak all the time and in steak
or burgers just beef just red meat in
general on the carnivore diet i eat like
a big cat at the zoo right so if a big
cat then you have the zoo your boy
doesn't touch it so i'm always grilling
and then my you know my my son or boss
or something he wants something so i was
grilling my meat and then i put it you
know it was done so i put it on the
the [ __ ]
whatever the
the the plate to bring inside and my son
called me to do something over he like
won his car out he like lost his car
there's like a lizard so he's scared of
the [ __ ] lizard so i go over there to
help him i forgot i left the grill on
i left the the gas grill on
i don't even think about i go in the
house eat my food do my thing mean tea
go in the hot dog we're doing our thing
days go by
i get a call days go by and i get a call
from uh my business manager goes hey we
got a call from the gas company
you have a gas leak like what
so
it's really important the amount of gas
that's coming out there is not good man
you guys need to figure it out it's very
dangerous so i call my girl i'm in
studio i'm thinking i'm doing king
stingo hey get out of the house
there's a gas leak they just called me
somebody's coming right now they rush
over they make their like five minutes
they're searching all over the [ __ ]
house they're checking everything it's
super natural gas super dangerous right
they're checking everywhere
finally go you left the grill on for
seven days oh [ __ ] then we look at the
the by that we have a pool in the
backyard we have like uh a canopy that
you know blocks the sun so we can chill
in the shade that thing started to catch
on fire
and i think if it happens to your fault
you're kind of [ __ ] i mean i have
insurance and stuff but you'd be pretty
[ __ ] man the house burned down oh that
would suck balls for sure so with steph
and bonner do we know why it burned out
they don't know why yet they're selling
a long story and that's the story that's
to guess chris deleo says and that's it
but for bonner what happened wait real
quick um i left my light on too on my
stove for
i think almost two days i turned it
really low i forgot i had it on yeah yep
so just be careful out there yeah no i'm
on it now
all right let me just play this for you
real quick this is him filming all the
damage
no more casa
no more costumes burned to the [ __ ]
ground
everything in it the neighbor's house do
man everything in it but i just climbed
into the window
cut my shins open both of them bunch of
shards of glass
and look what i got man
clothes from the forest fight jesus
season one jersey jesus christ
signed by everyone
at the vanilla garilla
loden sincade
there he is
rest in peace buddy
and
team windell
and the chicago golden globes it's been
a rough year for season one man hang in
there leaving
[ __ ] hang in there diego you were
great the other week by the way so proud
of you [ __ ] swift beat that [ __ ]
cancer and i almost kicked the bucket
earlier this year it's a better [ __ ]
[ __ ] here for me too so
all right peace guys come on
and he has a gofundme yeah and the cool
thing about this is uh so as soon as mma
fighters found out about it they all
kind of wanted to chip in and tyron
woodley was one that he thinks the most
because he put in like four grand and he
posted about it too
so he started it all basically
and does he still need money or he met
his i think they met the goal this is
what he wrote about
how the gofundme got started with his
wife tyrone a few times this blew me
away thanks everyone oh wow can we still
donate yeah i mean let's see right here
what the goal was
ten thousand dollar goal it's already at
12 8 35. i might as well give him as
much as possible i'll give two thousand
dollars right now boom
uh so go to donate now but i mean we'll
get your all your information on yeah we
can edit this out donate now
all right dude we donated that's awesome
that you did that dude two g's for the
stefan bonner dude so he's at almost
five fifteen thousand buckaroos actually
15 15 km
hopefully that helps man oh definitely
dude dude we're all in this together the
ufc alumni stick
together dude
and that's a beautiful thing you would
like you'd think the ufc would donate
somewhat though i hope they do
you would see it on there right i mean
because maybe i would say this so you
know and i'm not
i've helped a ton of people i don't
shout out about or blast online you know
but
you know
you would the ufc does help a lot of
people
um behind the scenes you know they paid
for bobby green's that was amazing
funeral and they do a lot of brothers
that's right when i say son
also people dude
times are tough right now so people
donating you know 20 bucks 10 is [ __ ]
awesome man do what whatever you can
donate you know
shout out to adam hunter for putting
fifty dollars
i think he's hilarious man
yeah so hopefully that helps man i can't
imagine lose your home nice crib too the
place is sweet i was actually a little i
was like i didn't think his house is
gonna be that nice i mean neither do you
do it for him hopefully
you know with insurance and all that
[ __ ] yeah
all right um this is jake paul on tmz
okay um he mentioned before that he
would kill conor in the first round
right
mma boxing in mma
and this is what he says here
[Music]
uh he says connor is on a downhill
spiral his limbs are all broken so stand
up game i'm coming out knock him out
first round
uh jake also said he wants to throw down
with mcgregor in the ufc uh he tried to
persuade dana white to give more of the
company's revenue to fighters see the
payout for dana and aria emanuel no i
think danny got paid like i don't know
300 mil or 250 mil
but he should yeah of course dude he's
such a huge figure i mean he did so much
for sure if i went dan has to increase
the minimum of fighter pay
if i lose they can take all of the money
and whatever and so be it but i know i
can beat connor if the matchup kind of
doesn't happen there's still a chance
jake has mma for his next fight
regardless
he's been talked about torn pfl and
other mma and entities trying to help
some kind of deal
he's got to do it at the fc though if it
ever happens
and yeah but here here's the thing again
this is kind of the same thing with
francis and tyson fury
if i'm the ufc hey man this is happening
regardless
why not get a piece of the pie
you guys like sweet pie i like sweet pie
why not get involved in this piece of
the pie that pie's getting made
whether it's a year from now two years
from now that pie is [ __ ] in the oven
dude and you guys want to slice jump on
in daddy
get you some of the pie
i don't i don't know what the hesitation
is
i would say jake paul is more
suited to fight compete in the ufc than
uh [ __ ] cm punk without a doubt yeah
yeah professional fights conor doesn't
have that many more years
and again do it ufc
conrad's gonna make all the money in the
world jake's gonna make all the money
where in the world it's happening
play ball with this kid i know you guys
don't like him or whatever play ball
them
i think jake's biggest thing of why
they're not
in cahoots with them is the fighter pay
thing because
it's so much bigger
than just a conor jake fight because if
they change the pay scale for the
newer fighters on that uh
rookie contract
you're talking millions upon millions
and millions of dollars for many many
years
for the rest of the time because they're
not going to go backwards once you give
someone you know increase in pay you
can't go backwards
so
if he's actually about this fight
he i'm sure the ufc if they're like all
right we'll play game we'll play ball
but
we're not going to do the increased
fighters pay
you you can donate your purse to whoever
you want do that but
you know it'd be a win-win though it
would look good on the ufc to do it even
if it's just a small amount not a crazy
yeah even if it's an additional again
even if they said all right we'll
increase the win bonus to a thousand
dollars you're talking millions and
millions and millions and millions at
all roster is huge which they can't
afford you know but
so it's a bit bigger than jake but um i
also think if the ufc were to do this
and jake did get the fighter pay
situation taken care of
you're talking fan favorite yeah
you would love him for this love him so
i hope hopefully it works out first of
all connor's half his size right now
who's this anthony smith okay first of
all connor's half his size right now not
true connor's actually probably the same
size as him okay connor watched around
at around 190. jake paul is 190 fights
at 190 so say you watched it 210. so
half of that would be uh 105. so he's
not 105. so half his size right now
that's not working for me people do miss
that jake's a big dude and he's fighting
short stocky wrestler welterweights jake
paul's my size he's a big goddamn dude
jake paul is not the size of anthony
anthony smith is [ __ ] two that's
pretty annoying like 6'4
240 or whatever the [ __ ] he is he's a
great fighter phenomenal analyst too a
beast best teeth in mma as well hammer
darren till whoever you want to go with
uh jake paul's he's a big goddamn dude
he's way north of 200 pounds i don't
think he's way north he's not that big
he's actually kind of stocky his
brother's taller
him finding conor in a boxing match
that'd probably be a pretty good fight
to be honest with you but is he going to
knock him on mma fight no not when conor
gets kicked in he's going to kick jake
paul's head right off his shoulders
people say that jake can rest a little
bit so he might be able to keep it a
little bit more competitive for a minute
or so but no in an mma fight he's going
to get barbecued
i
i disagree
i disagree i don't
i don't think he gets barbecued i think
it's intriguing matchup surprisingly i
think
jake would be the slower fighter i think
in a boxing match he it definitely
goes more towards jake paul's way and
boxing he doesn't have to worry about
the kicks and stuff like that um does he
beat conor mcgregor probably not that's
you know i think conor speed and
experience and you know creativity
inside that gun probably and then also
his grappling jiu jitsu would be a huge
issue for jake
but jake does hit harder if he can land
but i do think speed would be the
biggest issue for jake paul inside that
octagon also
um
i was gonna say also you know there's
ufc jitters there's such thing as ufc
jitters
but these [ __ ] paul brothers i told
you man when i worked for show time when
i went in the locker room when he's
fighting mayweather these kids don't
give a [ __ ] they grew up with a camera
in their face the moment cannot get
bigger so for him to fight in a main
event in ufc i literally don't think it
phases this kid they're [ __ ] aliens
dude which is insane to say
i would personally love a jake paul
connor fight would love and here again
i'm gonna emphasize this it's gonna
happen
no matter if the ufc allows it or not
it's going to happen whether it's a year
from now or two years from now if i'm
the ufc and i'm a businessman which i am
i want some of that delicious cherry
jake paul conor mcgregor pie
it's happening that thing's the oven's
already preheating
get involved dude
get your hands in on that hot pot
you know what i'm saying yep
i'd love to see that fight too it was
weird that's a weird take from anthony
smith though
no he did go on to say good things about
you but he didn't want he said i don't
hate the guy i actually kind of like him
helping fighters out all that good yeah
yeah and i love anthony smith too
he's staying here for a long time man
such good analyst yeah great [ __ ]
teeth too amazing teeth uh so the ceo of
one champion or one
shot tree sitting down he mentioned cha
tree's great love chauchi love one
championship i was
super into their last fight the one
championship we covered on this broken i
promoted on my social i love one
championship i love what they're doing
love chauchi love what he's about
especially when it comes to fighter
stuff like that
uh so he's saying this from chauchi this
is all news me whenever so whenever we
do these current events i have no idea
what chin's going to bring up you guys
are seeing straight up
real-time response to this [ __ ] so he
says i like francine gano but i think
our heavyweights would smoke him
it's just not a complete fighter for
sure if you ask any expert martial
artist you look at one
champion antoli malikin russian national
pedigree wrestler dynamite in his hands
much faster than francis much better
ground game black belt level he was also
submission champion europe you look at
one uh heavyweight champ uh arjun buller
wrestle wrestler boxing
france is not very impressive on the
ground he's got a big looping punch he's
not technical boxer as an antholy or
arjun chaudry love ya
absolutely love you obviously i'm biased
ufc here because that's my background
right
you're crazy
but here's what i do like about chauchi
he rides or dies for his guys he should
be what what what would you like him to
say
oh yeah francis the guy who has who's
not involved in our organization would
completely dominate my guys no
you're gonna say hey we have the best
heavyweights if you wanna you know fancy
yourself the best in the world come on
over and fight our heavyweights that'd
be a huge sign for one championship
business move business transaction
business
kind of england there obviously francis
is not signed with ufc and he's a free
agent
still so maybe he's trying to entice him
to come over there
but as far as
saying that he's not even close to these
guys level
and i've watched both these men fight
great good fighters one did compete in
ufc
didn't blow the
you know blow your hair back didn't take
over the world definitely was at world
championship uh pedigree in the ufc you
know the ufc i think had had him fight
three fights there is arjun singh
bueller in the ufc that's him there
hairy chest built like mike that's
whatever
neither one would last a single round
with franciano
not right now i don't think no
no
but yeah i hear what you're saying gotta
talk up your boys
this anthony has a much better chance
but they're smaller be it it'd be a
tough night in the office for both of
them
but if i'm chautry i'm doubling down on
my guys and i respect it but not a
chance not a chance hey we know this
though right i mean
thing i don't know about that speed
thing
so this is davison figuereto you know
the so the fourth match with him and
brandon raider was already pretty much
done deal yeah i thought it was booked
thought it was science delivered but
then he asked dana white to not do that
and to fight kai kar france because he
believes brandon moreno and his team are
racist against him racist racist racist
towards brazilians to him okay dear
daniel i just want to say thank you for
the opportunities that you have who's
this talking right now this is davidson
davidson says thank you for the
opportunity of giving me my family my
country figarito wrote on instagram you
know that i would fight anybody anytime
anywhere that being said
he said that's being said uh just be
that being said i wanted to fight brent
moreno for the fourth time because i
i know this is what the fans want until
this team crossed the line with the
racist comments call me a monkey and i'm
going to extend photoshopping a monkey's
face on top of mine you know what i'm
talking about
rule underscore in trim when all this
happened i went on a campaign to stop
racist and prejudice in my city it was
predominantly indians and blacks as the
ufc champion of the world as you
consider my wish i wish to fight the
next contender in line kai kara france i
would love to see that fight who has
earned his spot
hashtag stop the racism hashtag we we
are one
all right so obviously brian responded
to it
moreno's not racist no no
i
said this in spanish but i'm going to
read in english
clearly this is bram rayner responding
he says it's just stupid ramsay in
spanish he was playing with his phone
and he was streaming live on instagram
and he was using my many filters it's a
shame we don't have the full video
because it was a live stream he didn't
save it he was using filters on everyone
dana white my teammates he even used a
filter on me i was switching filters
then a monkey uh filter on figuerito
that's true and someone took a
screenshot we don't know who when he
starts calling
marcio rojo a racist you know martial
you're not going to let let me lie he's
not racist although moreno appears to
understand since through the issues at
hand he doesn't think it's a good reason
for ufc to switch gears and give kai
kara france the next style shot over him
mourinho is convinced figary is just
trying any tactics to avoid the fourth
fight he said i've already talked to ufc
with the top guys in the promotion they
told me the fourth fight is set at some
point they told me not to worry the plan
is for me to fight again for the title
so i think at this point davidson is
running away from me i'm not lying
you'll see once dave sinfigurito brian
moreno four i said yes already but the
other part hasn't
and then
here uh
who's this talking this is mourinho so
mario says he needs to understand that
he's still the b side on this and that's
not my fault i'm just here to fight and
be the best chance for him to lose this
fight against me are very high sees a
better opportunity for carrick france
to keep the belt and make some money but
he knows the only money fight for him is
with me simple facts he's so stupid come
on figarito
come on yeah he's not fighting for the
fourth time stop for the racist [ __ ]
obviously you should notice by now dana
doesn't give a [ __ ]
what's this all right this is pretty
cool news on the whole chill son and
stuff so he has i think it was four or
five battery charge failing battery
charge just dropped 10 total yeah or 10
or 11 and then now he has he still has
six misdemeanors but they're
misdemeanors so it doesn't seem like oh
where do you mean that ark that they
wrote from
the victim wasn't all true
it's looking so
crazy weird it's like i'm defending guy
because i know what i'm talking about
weird
so initially was charged with
misdemeanor battery charge in january
but the charge was dismissed without
prejudice with the left with which left
the option for the charge to be refiled
and subsequent court filing march 14th
sonan was charged with a felony count of
battery by strangulation and 10
misdemeanor counts of battery he now
sees his charges reduced to six
misdemeanor counts after wednesday's
hearing
he's going back in too
but that's good news yeah great news
weird yeah this is also weird ben
rothwell he was supposed to fight
alexander gustafsson i've never heard of
them booking a guy fight and then
cutting him yeah i wonder if he was
making some weird demands or something i
think did rothwell talk about on his
twitter or anything i didn't see
anything on it
how funny was it when we had josh
barnett i had material and me
on on the
cowboys fight campaign and we brought up
ben rothwell he's beat all of us
hilarious um dad that's january 20th
they put that bell on no date in the
cage
and that was january training yeah so
maybe it doesn't really go on weird
social media
but yeah so i mean it could be anything
i was talking to mike earlier he might
be a struggle to work with or he's been
dude
that's definitely not well known i mean
he's been in the game so long
um but yeah and also i don't i wonder
because he's been popped before i wonder
if that could you know it'll come out
yeah
what else got you i have this
oh sean o'malley was talking about jorge
mazdan he's saying they're raised
differently jorge comes from the streets
so that's like gangster [ __ ] that he was
doing
there's nothing gangster about that i
know and then he also brought up he goes
uh
that leon edwards thing remember he
actually
kind of did like a will smith chris rock
thing to leon edwards even though
edwards called him out he just said july
to fight and then jorge had his heads
behind your back walked up to him and
then just remember the three pieces in
the center of soda yeah so it's like
he's been doing this mm-hmm yeah kobe
post five days ago
five days in a row 50 45 50 45 50 45
talking chip there's a fine line between
entertainment making a personal kobe was
on the entertainment line where he was
on the personality i think colby was on
the personal line too it's not a good
look for george people loved it when he
did to the unknown words i'm a fan of
both
this on theo's podcast by the way my
word
yeah i'm a fan of all of them um it's
just a shame there's nothing gangster
about sucker sucker punching i covered
it on the show last week there's nothing
gangster about it there's nothing tough
about it tough guys don't do that
i don't care what
background you have what street you grow
up what area code you come from there's
i
as far as i know from the streets of
aurora colorado
there is nothing tough about sucker
punch in a guy it's so cowardly in any
facet yep there's it's just just a [ __ ]
move
i told you i hope the ufc disciplines
mazda all by making fight him again
and giving kobe all the pay-per-view
points that's what i think they should
do i agree
um this is an interesting thing that
john jones
recently said i also heard john jones
say he's ready for a july fight he's
just july yeah yeah it's going to be
steep bay i'm telling you on that big
card have you using the announcement
amazing you'll fight companies for me so
lit
yeah so this is the first time i've ever
seen him say this something like this
because remember when he fought dominick
reyes
him he said as him and his team watch
the fight again they're like no we
definitely want all those all this stuff
but
now he's saying since my candle for
light heavyweight blew out showed my
last fight instead of being discouraged
by a bad performance i stoked i'm stoked
about this new season my energy my time
at light heavyweight was over
i see that more clear today than ever i
told you guys i think with john you know
with the anthony smith fight
the uh
the santos fight and then with dominic
ray's fight he j you're just not getting
the best version of jon jones because he
just can't get up for these guys yeah
he's talking about the guys fought the
who's who
for his entire career he's been doing it
so long
to me he's the pound-for-pound greatest
to ever do it outside his antics of the
octagon he's still the bound for pound
best that we ever had to offer i don't
see anybody beating him and i think he
um
it was just hard for him to get up for
the fights for these young lines that
nobody really knew and they posed all
this [ __ ] threats to him and he still
you know kind of got it done even though
some of you think he lost the dominic
reyes fight understandable but
um i
i would watch him and i from
my opinion it just didn't seem he was
very into the fight you still got it
done that's how [ __ ] talented this
dude is so i'm excited for him at
heavyweight man him versus stipe is the
f freaking fight it's if i can make any
fight besides mcgregor jake paul this is
up there jon jones steve pays the fight
i don't see jon jon stipe than
even john francis right now i really
want jon jones stipe that's what i want
if i if i was dana white i was bald i
had all the money in the world
and i'm sitting in my house in newport
my neighbors are [ __ ] like tyson and
conor mcgregor and they came up to me
all right you make one fight what do you
want to do i go announce john stipe july
big ufc expo card goose
the other brain busters chin this is
pretty badass so the guy yaroslav amazon
who's the killer in bellators
yup but stayed in his home country
yeah stayed in his home country to the
fight
this is him in his home country and he
uh i guess his mom saved his belt and
hid it somewhere so it wouldn't get
damaged and he was able to find it
holy [ __ ]
wow
powerful stuff man
[Laughter]
that's so cool
as you see there it says it survived the
bombing
terrible man
you've seen the news and even this one's
showing dead bodies on the streets of
mass graves i can't believe it's 2022
and we're looking at this in real time i
cannot [ __ ] believe that
yeah shout out to
yaroslav amazov almost off man what a
fat complete badass
okay uh you mentioned kelvin gasoline so
i just want to go down the timeline here
real quick so he was initially supposed
to fight uh nostradini imivov yes stuff
and then nacho dean couldn't get his
visa so then luckily rodriguez duplessi
came in and was able to do it last
minute but then now there's an
undisclosed injury with kevin kelvin
gaslum so he's actually withdrawing
that's tough man
great career
great career yeah
okay there's a cool one real quick so
jessica is going to fight that
up-and-comer who's killing her now casey
neistat
yeah casey o'neill is a monster for sure
when gfc 276 that's three away from now
jesus christ
276 date
july 2nd perfect
tell you the main event on that's give
me john jones stephen
all right uh so we were talking about if
there's any fights over the weekend this
one happened at cage warriors and check
out this ko
kick
and dude's name is manny akpan
fun
and oh
so
you know fabricio verdum joined pfl so
he's not going to do this he's pulling
out of the 2022 tournament thing and
he's considering retirement now god one
of the greatest ever do it top five of
all time no matter what organization top
five of all time first guy to do or
first got it really similar yeah submit
fedor i'm talking like really actually
somebody yeah trying to talk about mma i
think sorry for me to come back because
it's more dedication staying two three
months the united states i'm living in
brazil for a year and three months now
if there's a box match i'd do it i don't
want to see unboxings summing up boxing
yes mma no it would need to be an out of
this world offer to make me stop doing
what i've been doing right now
well more power to him i absolutely love
[ __ ] for doom yeah
uh this is we already know that patty
pemblett likes to on his off days when
he's not in camp he likes to eat and
gains a ton of weight oh yeah so he's
already surpassed 200 pounds since he's
lost white he's the real meatball yeah
he's all fun and games to get older
batty
it's so insane over tour and what's he
just eating whatever you have like your
cakes ice cream
just everything good for him it's on his
vlog cuts all that weight yeah
it's insane 155
it's over like maybe 60 pounds nuts
insane yeah not the best way to go about
things
so she's ufc he's like hey short notice
fight you're like what oh his face yeah
it balloons up like crazy yep yep boy he
is that boy
uh all right going back to uh jorge
mazda
you know about the governor ron desantis
yes he's uh
he did this
re-election private fundraiser and he
actually had jorge mason i'll come up
and give him i guess the bmf belt and
also talk
which is interesting because you know
jorge is in
a little bit of trouble right now
jorge is a fighter he ran to another
fighter it's not like he beat him up
beat up some kid on the street
uh look it happens he's a fighter for
freedom i think we all support him
that's from senator manny diaz jr
interesting that they make sense i know
can't be sucker-punching people and
the the world's just weird that's pretty
ballsy to have them on yeah if you're
running for awesome it is good for jorge
for them trying to power through it it's
like the same with the
the will smith and [ __ ]
chris rock slap you know it's just
it's so strange speaking of that slap
this is what henry who said henry had
said about al james
chris rock how many roles would he have
done after getting slapped
i don't know why he has stuff against
him but
yeah talking smack
and i'll finish off with this one
remember the iranian hulk and martin
ford
the iron hook that was instagram famous
because he looks good gigantic but he
really isn't yeah he's kind of just a
short fat guy yeah dude so apparently oh
this is what's happening tonight oh no
yeah he's crying playing there's a video
you can't tell so then you show the
crying part it just shows him talking
can i get some subtitles
he's a bigger dude but definitely not as
big as we thought
and so he says like so he's not doing
well no he says i cannot call my family
when i returned i didn't i didn't go to
my family karibee
the iranian hulk says i can't talk to my
father and my mother when i spoke to her
she said the person in this video that i
saw was not my son my son was way
stronger than this it hurts my head when
i can't talk to my family i've lost my
pride and i am destroyed but why won't
they talk to him i guess because it was
embarrassing when he got pushed and
fell down remember when martin ford
pushed him and he just flew and then he
tried to take him down and it looked
horrific
so how can i explain they deceived me
and i fell to the ground
my family said that you you will go
there and finish him they expected the
other way around how can i sleep or get
any rest i personally feel very bad and
cannot sleep but i am now taking
sleeping pills not in a good place oh
he's not going to take the no that's
exactly what martin luther fight
yeah it's all it's all hype i'm uh this
is ford this is uh ford martin ford said
this i'm question i am
asking the question if he genuinely
wants to fight me because i don't want
to step in a ring and be perceived as a
bully and seen as intimidating someone
who hasn't put in the same work in as i
have
um i expect to be serious about fighting
that he gets his ass into gear because i
don't want to disappoint people at the
event
oh it's hey and it's already all set to
happen
hey
hey hey martin ford it's not happening i
can't imagine the guy's uh internet
sensation and that's it he can't fight
sir and we saw that when you pushed fake
and then he did that terrible takedown
which wasn't very athletic at all
oh no no hey martin ford it ain't
happening
definitely not happening
in any fashion yeah that fight's never
happening it's never gonna compete so
there you go i'll take it from here hey
martin not happening
is that it that is it
all right kids that's it uh cowboy says
fight companion on the thick boy youtube
this saturday 7 p.m pacific matt matrion
josh thompson brian cowan and myself
will be live at 7 pm so tune in to the
cowbest fight command for ufc 273 also
this saturday at 10 30 a.m your boy is
running the thick mudder we're offering
a 15k and a 5k the thick boy crew will
be there come run with me and mark
harley and some of the other boys from
the thick boy crew you've seen you guys
love them
uh rock your thick boy uh thick mudder
t's as well all right but we will be
there loud and proud it's a 5k and 15k
promise you i will promise you this
i have not been training for this i
completed the last one
without two hamstrings it's more about
the experience it's bonding it's such a
goddamn good time i can't wait i'll see
you guys saturday at 10 30 a.m is the
start time 5k 15k use promo code sickboy
for 10 off go to toughmudder.com you
will see the thick boy heat um it's all
over my social media too so you can't
miss it wednesday hollywood improv shop
and friends and i've uh
probably my two most talented friends
will be on the show theo vaughn and
crystalia and myself will be doing the
shaban friends this saturday 8 p.m april
6 8 p.m one show only at the hollywood
improv and then next week thursday
friday saturday i'm in phoenix arizona
your boy will be at jt wings on saturday
eating all the wings in the world i will
be at stand up live with the thick boy
crew david lucas chappelle lacy myself
phoenix arizona europe on the thick boy
tour
that is uh one show thursday to friday
to saturday at the stand up live in
phoenix arizona then april 22nd through
the 23rd is the moon tower comedy
festival your boys headline that the cap
cities the new cap cities uh it's the
moon tower comedy festival so get
tickets at thickboy.com or fatkz.com
for austin texas april 22nd to 23rd and
then the special drops on thick boy
on april 28th you will see all the
marketing going towards that date on the
28th billboards sizzles everything your
boy's funding himself doing himself
let's ride stand up thick boys let's
blow this thing up april 28th the brand
new special drops all right that's that
thick boy youtube get you some
and then may philadelphia may 19th
through 21st get you some philly tickets
at thinkboy.com but phoenix
phoenix arizona europe next week
thursday friday saturday stand up live
take you to thinkboy.com see you at the
thick mudder this saturday at 10 30 a.m
see you at 7 p.m on youtube thick boy
for the calabasas fight companion at 7
pm on thick boy youtube that's it
stay safe be nice to each other love you
guys thank you for liking watching
subscribing you guys give me the best
job in the world i love you go donate to
our boy stefan bonner's gofundme i know
his goal was 10 000 but i'm sure he
needs more
so go to his gofundme right now stephen
bonner lost his house let's support him
rally around him that's what we do love
you guys stay
[Music]
through the city like safe shaw if you
ain't think please don't get involved